six mother five and thirty in the
morning who's out here sparking with the
[ __ ] pigeons
[Music]
6:30 in the morning was out there
sparking with [ __ ] pigeon school
yong-chol Joey that's who the restaurant
yeah there's a great time we get the
[ __ ] out of here
I was in bed right after a [ __ ] fight
ready to rock understand me I'm a
[ __ ] Refik Maureen more the 7:30 mass
I'm gonna say a prayer for most of you
got suckers out there put a couple of
dollars in the box and that's it how did
you do it 12
Podcast I go to surgery tomorrow morning
I'm getting to the [ __ ] up
with all these [ __ ] about Molly wanna
beats not worry but the only one who's
here
is a fat [ __ ] 53 troll sparking with
you [ __ ] why because I got
nothing but heart that's why and if you
ain't that heart there's gonna be a long
[ __ ] my field you could get your
little tattoo when your little goatee
your little shirt and and flow through
the [ __ ] life but you could be a
[ __ ] Savage you understand me
speaking of savages
we're at the tail end of this [ __ ]
little [ __ ] cookies that is some of
the best team I have to some joint which
with the description of the we would
only want to see clouds we're gonna see
[ __ ] red eyeballs
I'm which he understand me but is Sunday
so there's a whole hum type of day gonna
start the [ __ ] reflow slowly I
haven't even had my [ __ ] smoothie yet
I just had a capacity at all cold fat
stomach metabolism to eat up your body
so you [ __ ] off and run against them
forget cereal or [ __ ] all that
[ __ ]
I gotta look deep in the murky waters
now it's all over black people getting
shot while you [ __ ] doing you sitting
there listen to the [ __ ] air quitter
fine you got to do something
you got to stand up for yourself
nice
what a way to start the morning some
breathing exercises my doctor police
everybody wash my [ __ ] it's nice and
[ __ ] fresh ready to go these people
leave the house but I [ __ ] your
washing their [ __ ] over there you
filthy [ __ ] call me a [ __ ]
hand wash that [ __ ] been cementing
on [ __ ] at night and you wanna clock
madam [ __ ] you you [ __ ] another dirty
[ __ ] nasty friends
[Music]
smoke signals you understand me if a car
my mom's gonna [ __ ] show up in about
three minutes Indians is slipping
because I'm sending [ __ ] smoke
signals beep it means help this reefer
is too [ __ ] good you understand
I love smoking good we for the more
that's my time most people wanna go out
I'd never better than when I got up at
6:00 a.m.
hope the hell up at 5:30 you gotta hit
that briefly clears the mind it makes
the way for the rest of the [ __ ] day
you understand
I tell you I'm a little nervous about
the surgeon about I'd only be blood all
over my face like [ __ ] me should take
she fought a [ __ ] war last night how
about my girl Misha that [ __ ] Brock
lesner fight I might as well cut my
fungi tall male and yeah it was what it
was I taught you [ __ ] the best
fighter year was average it's don't sign
yes I've been saying it for [ __ ]
months nobody believes me nobody
believes the fat little [ __ ] Cuban we
while you sleep and understand
don't gonna do this how you're gonna do
it under the word step you're gonna do
it this is but you never got up two
hours before everybody else in have your
own little piece of [ __ ] mind right
here by the time they can get up you
take a nap
that's how I am
just me the trees
not even the [ __ ] the world sort of
lump them to [ __ ] are they're all
right you need to get a ticket
that's rival ball football team but
three winners you're gonna [ __ ] be a
Marine you gotta be up early we think if
you can I would GI change and up with GI
Joe you're [ __ ] thinking dealing with
some novice then I love this pineapple
expression I'm smoking dead that's it's
the [ __ ] morning on an empty stomach
I'm hearing voices on her own people
yelling
I love that you join me in the morning
and this little tape top tank you know
we start the down the right foot that's
all this is about starting it down the
right foot you know how to walk on coals
but Anthony [ __ ] Hopkins it and help
it just kind of show up at the [ __ ]
screen smoke with yong-chol Joey right
you close down and then your mind to set
your plan understanding what's my plan
of [ __ ] attack everybody else is
sleeping no it's great nice meanwhile
your [ __ ] plot
they kidding me are you kidding me even
these [ __ ] wannabe [ __ ] ass
market just a soldiers soldiers
Master these [ __ ] read my
thoughts tickle spread knowledge today
little [ __ ] buddies at the coffee
shop well I heard this isn't even over
30 get the [ __ ] out of it I'm over here
smoking with four [ __ ] arms like like
a [ __ ] octopus
look at those [ __ ] clouds right there
I feel good
I'm ready to take on the day
and I woke up I was a will have a thing
that made him saying we all love I'm
they're gonna hate me
nobody loves gonna get the [ __ ] there
you go on that show you watch that
[ __ ] monkey and you take three hit to
this [ __ ] and then forget about it my
[ __ ] Mussolini on a good day
where do you go
I'm gonna have my little funky smoothie
I'm gonna go to 7:30 men's I'm gonna sit
in the back to spin on me I'm a [ __ ]
Center from day one
I'm sit the front way to rest these
hypocrites happen the board is great
that they go for some Chinese chick
after with a massage ball up the ass for
the small 49 Uncle Joe I sit but back
then all my creepy [ __ ] do it I say
if you praise me you can't suckers I get
some holy water and I get the [ __ ] ahead
before nobody even sees me you know why
don't make this evening
nobody wants to be seen how nobody say
no no no Bonnie I wish a nobody I just
want to set the back and look at the
picture Jesus hanging up there feel bad
I super get in the car I smoke another
bone and I catch the weed store at 10:08
still opens up like at 9:30 I know
people in the back door
and that's it and that's that it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you only get one of these every [ __ ]
day get up get out there let these
[ __ ] no less suffer with the
understanding
they should be coming storm to the Gulf
and yes Eddie never got before you but
okay look a little bad boy have Equal
Employment give a ring cannot be no
sorry
I checked it will you concerns later
that's an old piece of gum that was just
sitting there with an ant planet I don't
give a [ __ ] I got the immune system of a
[ __ ] and he'll understand anyone I'd
love you [ __ ] stay black I have
a great day
don't let nobody [ __ ] with you and
always have a plan goodness damn it
catch you later
the guilt-free can't wait the
[ __ ] cookies at church I'm a
monkey that I'm asking for tutoring
stay black concepts